your teachers union is that open to any
teachers are only charter school
teachers or on a grand on teachers our
contract has been used in negotiations
around the country it's a about a 30
page contract the essentials of at are
we don't have tenure we have just caused
so you have to have a can't just fire
people that will have some protections
we don't have minutes and hours in a
work day it's a professional work day so
there's no clocking in and out this
isn't a factory model performance is
part of your evaluation but the teachers
part of the evaluation process and guess
what teachers are harder on each other
then we would be which is exciting we
pay teachers ten percent more in Los
Angeles and fourteen percent more in our
union partnership school in New York I
mean ultimately it mirrors exactly the
vision of our charters you know and so
if you think like I do I think union
contracts are written in reaction to
systems and you can't find more messed
up systems in urban education so if you
create a model it's got a pretty
decentralized pro teacher model the
reaction to it's going to be less and I
just think that's that's a potential
game changer in this game so we can get
past this this turf war and the tribes
and really focus on what what the 75% we
agree on